quand on a égalisé je savais qu'on
allait qu'on allait gagner ce
[Musique]
match beaucoup de joie beaucoup de joie
et juste un un sentiment de de fierté
parce que je vous avoue que jeis dans de
telles conditions seulle face à tous
c'est pas évident et quand tu ressors de
là avec une victoire tu as juste envie
de dire félicitation à tes C éipier
parce que ils ont tout donné ils n'ont
rien lâché jusqu'à la fin on y a cru et
au final on reçort Victo de ce de ce
match donc félicitations à eux le mérit
là revient sur la première mi-temps je
pense qu'on avait un peu peur de on
avait un peu peur du résultat et à la
fin deè miemps on s'est lâché parce
qu'on savait qu'on avait plus choix on a
un peu on s'est un peu raté sur les deux
premiers matchs de de pool et on avait
vraiment à cœur de de faire un gros
match aujourd'hui on a montré qu'on
était une belle équipe et qu'on peut
aller lo dans cette compétition allez
[Musique]
ouaisil directement quand on a encaissé
j'ai vu comment les gars ils voulaient
baisser les bras il voulaiit baisser la
tête euh du coup je me suis d'abord
dirigé vers Zambo le capitaine pour lui
dire qu'il faut pas qu'il donne image
faut qu'il se relève mais que déjà si on
marque les les les minutes qui suivent
on pourra avoir l'opportunité de de de
marquer ensuite le trè but et c'est ce
qui s'est passé on a montré qu'on était
uni qu'on lâchait rien et qu'on était un
groupe en devenir et quand on nous pense
mort et en difficulté on est là on
l'avait prouvé pour la qualification de
Coupe du monde à Blida et encore une
fois donc j'ai l'impression que ça
rentre aussi dans notre
ADN